ANY REVELATIONS NUARY 6th COMMI.
JAMES CARVERAS
YOU KNOW WHAT I'
>>> MY NEXT GUEST DE IEAE IN PO
MA HURDL
BROUGHTUM
DI FORMEL
PRAIRST FO MAGAZINE.
THANK YOH FOG
EVED, ED HE TH HAVE
DEE E   I
DEFENSE IM PROVI
CRIMES THAT YOU LISTED AOM
AGO.
RGACY TO DEFUDTE O
CODEFRAUD THE ITED WHERED E ELES
STATES ISHONESTY. THAT'S ONE PRO
AND SIMIRLE THAT HONEST BELIEFOA
WELL.
>> I ASKED THAT QUESTION BAU
E PAYING CLOSE TOHE
WE'RE HEARING FROM ANY NUMBER O
HIM HE LOST.
THISOLD HI LOST.IF HE IN HISBEE
CASE.
ABOUT. T
MI E HERE I
DISHONEST ENABLERS OOUNDING THE.
RU THE  THEM ARE LAWYERS
RNEY
SO OF NEW YORK.
JOHN EASTM IS UPER T
UNIVERSITYCHO
YESTERDAY, HE CONTINUES E DOWN O
BU RAD PROBABLY A SMART LEGAL
STRATEGY THAT HE NOT GE CH IN T
W, , I KN
UMP ADMIW
ALL ALONG THAT THIS WAE  OERVA N
LOCL
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENTINK THEICR
HARIG HERECA AL PT ANOMA PROSEC
DEPARTMENT>> RENATO, THE JUSTIC
RTMENT HAS A PROTOCOL OR Y WER
,
CLE  TRUMPAMTHLLELECTION.
WILL TPR A OR IN ANYTHING TE IC
INCLINEDIS
IMPORTANTLY I THINRCOADER
THAL INDICT,  HEREF COURSE
CTN  CONCERN IS
SO AS  AHAT K THEY WOULDITOUS T.
THI TRS
THHERE ARE
ALWAYS -FOLKS AT HOME HAVEMEER
WH WELL , VERYD  TO LT WHAT PE S
CONVINCE THERWE.ST SOME JURORS D
P R .
ANP IS IN
WHERE HE -- HI MIND IS
HE A
DEPARTMENT IS HE WAS N HAN, ORL
RE THESES PRPENCE  THE CONIR
PROBLEMATIC GIVEN CT THAT E OF L
YOU HAVERSYES,
HAT THEY
W.'S TESTIMONY
TH TRUCH THA
GHGOING REME COU